instead of releasing X-Men 4 20th
Century Fox chose to focus on a prequel
of the franchise's most popular
character Wolverine the template for the
story was already there in the form of
the comic book miniseries origin all the
film would have to do is lift from The
Source material and adapt it to the big
screen and throw in Wolverine while
X-Men Origins Wolverine takes influence
from the comics it also veers off down a
tangent that didn't leave many viewers
happy for one the decision to make
saber-tooth and Wolverine Brothers feels
too much like a soap oper twist second
Gambit is introduced in the film but he
doesn't played nearly enough of a major
role and finally there's Deadpool by
refusing to give the Merk with a mouth a
costume and stitching his lips shut it
takes away everything that made the
character popular to begin with in the
years since then Ryan Reynolds Deadpool
movies have poked fun at how the
character was treated in this adaptation
there had been plans for a Magneto
origin film in the same vein as X-Men
Origins Wolverine however the lukewarm
reception towards the film and average
box office performance but have in the
idea what are you doing